[Music]
I'm James Marshall I'm not in the math
of the song the toughest footrace in the
world it's six marathons in five days
across the Sahara Desert I'm trained
like a crazy man
which is really boring so while my
powers to come on a job to keep me
company
this is jogging with James did you ever
think that your career would get you to
a place where you're on James in my
career at this point in my career you're
running the episode how comfortable you
were styling yourself Oh totally
actually I start by what you do yeah I
buy all their clothes I buy all her
shoes her heels the whole nine yards
pretty much your entire wardrobe what I
do as a photographer I like to go to the
quite sort of smart on top because I'm
not talking to clients on my knees to
photograph the ground or be active I do
something I like to call the fashion
mullet which is sort of a jacket on top
early a sports jacket on top maybe a
shirt and looser tie and then I'll wear
jeans on the bottom with a pair of
Converse so it's sort of business on top
party on the bottom you heard it here on
juggle change the fashion mullet there
you go being a handsome man and a very
talented artist
you really do have a soft place in your
heart for for me being a photographer
and having the ability to tell stories
through imagery by saying here's me in
the Arctic with a seal
during the seal hunt for the Humane
Society well here's mean Haiti but not
just talking about it but showcasing it
photographing it and saying to people
you make your mind up I'm not gonna tell
you you look at a picture and how do you
react so many of us have the opportunity
to give back I mean it doesn't remember
what organization or charity you're
working with the big part of it is just
getting educated on subjects that means
something to you
[Music]
so there's a game we play called shag
marry or push on the play
okay you got to tell me who you tried
who you'd marry and you push off this
okay we have Coco Karolina Wow
shag team Naomi
T
Mary Team Coco and push it off a cliff I
feel bad to push off a cliff team
Karolina
I wouldn't Karolina I would marry him
and thank you too buddy
okay so shag now push off their team
government J Alexander can Michael cause
I think I would have to push off a cliff
yeah this is the only one I know we
could climb back up again it'd be fine
Tim Gunn probably Mary
and then push up a cliff and then hang
myself see you shagging Michael cause my
mom I wasn't resurrected Matt check the
very talented very talented yeah come I
get a job out of it that's how fashion
works isn't it so Nigel thanks so much
for being on jogging with James really
appreciate it come on you want a dog
with this guy it's a bit of fun you can
push him around he's English is a
pushover and if you like this so before
you two follow us like us
hashtag GQ jock Nigel Barker was today
it's cured